what happens when some of the world's
deadliest carnivores go head to head
it's a war for survival
war is the law of the Jungle kill or be
killed
[Music]
Lee weapons
and an instinct to kill Death Or Glory
Soldier
welcome to the war
[Music]
welcome to Florida's Pinnacle of
predation
team feat and a thousand pounds of power
armor plating
[Music]
ADT
and 2 000 pounds of fight force but this
war machine at The Cutting Edge
the American alligator
but no alligator starts as the swamp's
deadliest
they start here
[Music]
these young Cadets are beginning their
long mission to become five-star swamp
generals
[Music]
water is full of Submarine enemies
the largemouth bass has radar lock
it's a highly mobile Hunter
a dedicated meat eater
now only two remain
alligators are ectothermic meaning they
must leave the water to warm their
bodies in the Sun
so must the water moccasin aka the
cottonmouth
it uses heat-seeking sensors to home in
on prey
its strike is accurate
and it's venom
deadly
it destroys tissue rupturing blood
vessels
the gator will slowly die
and the cottonmouth will dine
alone Gator Soldier survives
only he can complete the mission
but the largemouth bass is still not
done
[Music]
[Applause]
luckily for the Gator it's a frog that
fills its jaws
with every passing day
the Gator's odds improve
the bigger it grows
the viewer can tackle it
and in four years time
it will grow into an apex predator
[Music]
three
the iconic Bengal tiger needs no
introduction
500 pounds of hunting power
wherever this King walks his subject's
hail his approached
even when all he wants is a simple drink
of water
scars on his face tell story of violence
he must fight to wear the crown
a young Challenger squares off against a
dominant male
most disputes are settled with posturing
but the presence of a female raises the
stakes
the most aggressive encounters occur
when a female is ready to mate
[Music]
here's our arms with an arsenal of
deadly weapons
thank you
they probe each other's defenses
the dominant male latches on
gruesome kiss
[Music]
new way out is to submit to the pain
but this fight isn't over
to kill they must find the other's
throat
these encounters are rarely deadly
but there's always exceptions to the
norm
[Applause]
fur seals are a carnivorous colonial
power
they live all over the world chowing
down on whatever's available
foreign
fish in the subtropical Waters of South
Africa
and Shoals support a huge colony
but to get to the fish the hunters must
run the gauntlet
[Music]
great white sharks lurk in the channel
near The Colony
[Music]
it's safer to make the crossing in
numbers
sharks wait below looking for a sealed
silhouette to pass over
if they miss the first strike
chase is on
the shark has the power but the seal the
maneuverability it turns in tight
circles to escape the Jaws
before making the ultimate sacrifice
one seals death allows the others to
make it to the Shoals
[Music]
still have to get home
as this battle rages on
is about to begin
and some of the deadliest warriors in
the world are preparing for combat
[Music]
in the jungle there is one Golden Rule
stay alert stay alive now here the enemy
doesn't engage from hundreds of yards
away
when combat starts you're close enough
to see the whites of his eyes
or the blacks
frogs are jungle Commandos
with hundreds of species in the
rainforests of Central America alone
each is a deadly amphibious assault
weather that will kill pretty much
anything it can fit in its mouth
but they don't start out this way
most frogs simply lay their eggs and
abandon them
fodder to the elements
and to predators
but one ferocious father stands by his
young
the reticulated glass frog
he is hard
[Music]
guts
and guards his clutch
because squadrons of carnivorous
rainforest wasps
are incoming
it's not him thereafter it's his
precious eggs
please get a few tricks up his sleeve
his skin is patterned to look like the
eggs it draws the hungry wasps towards
him instead of the helpless Young
[Music]
foreign
-to-hand combat
of course there's only so much one
soldier can do
[Music]
to survive the tadpoles need to find the
will to fight
sensing danger some pop themselves out
prematurely
[Music]
hatching without being fully developed
is a better option than certain death
each surviving tadpole represents a
mission accomplished
dad's fighting Spirit lives on in a new
generation
the leopard is an adaptable Hunter
[Music]
foreign
stealth speed and strength
but nature is never neat and sometimes
even a top predator doesn't
she plans to eat or kill in peace
but they say plans are the first
casualty of War
a herd of buffalo Moves In
the efforts will occasionally take young
Buffalo
but the adults can be moody and in
numbers they can be lethal
[Music]
Smell Trouble
outnumbered the leopard will have to lay
low until the Buffalo let down their
guard next wild boars show up they smell
a meal
leverage are partial to a little Port
they can even take down the wild Boar's
more fearsome African cousin the warthog
battles can be hard fought
and gruesome
but tonight they get to eat her lunch
they could polish off the Corpse
if they stop bickering
now another carnivore exploits the
opportunity right under the leopard's
nose
a crocodile advances
[Applause]
these Predators sometimes compete with
the leopard for food
escape the crocodile and you might find
yourself in the clutches of the big cat
time for a roll reversal
it's too much for the leopard
she reclaims her kill and her dignity
from the small Croc
foreign
but the Buffalo closed ranks around her
forcing another chastening retreat
the leopard persists repeating the cycle
for hours
[Music]
this is Nature's fog of War there are no
Victors tonight
finally she retreats in dishonor
thank you Nature's war is not just
fought in the jungles
carnivores must fight in the deserts
the forests
and under the microscope
[Music]
the northern short-tailed shrew is on a
deadline
in three hours he will die
unless he hunts
his metabolism is so fast that only a
few hours without food will be the end
of them
his heart beats over four times faster
than a human
at up to 900 beats per minute
it sounds something like this
Mother Nature is cursed him with
insatiable hunger
but she's also given him the gift of
incredible weaponry
with animals with sonar
he can see with his ears like a bat
a mouse but the mouse
knows this game
stay still
stay silent
a faithful move
[Music]
a meal
just in the nick of time
but it offers only a short respite
the insatiable shrew must begin again
the northern leopard frog is also known
for its voracious appetite
a carnivore that will eat whatever it
can get its mouth around
a daunting opponent
of the Shrew is armed to the teeth he's
one of the few mammals with Venom
[Music]
it paralyzes his victim
keeping it fresh while it's being eaten
alive
[Music]
but satisfaction is only temporary
time is ticking
Chase
kill
repeat
[Music]
there is only one way to stop the clock
foreign
covert Ops
a war found in the shadows
it takes courage
stealth
and nerves of Steel
[Music]
the zodarian spider is the ultimate
mercenary
anteater but ants move in deadly armies
the spider must become an ant
to catch one
[Music]
she walks on six legs instead of eight
and raises her front too like antennae
mimicking her prey
[Music]
one ant stops for a bit of Grooming
a fatal mistake
she injects her Venom
full body paralysis
I don't know now for the hard part
Escape
she uses her victim as cover
She carries her still living prey like
she's an ant medic removing a casualty
[Music]
a suspicious Soldier probes with its
antennae
the tiny spider Taps them with her false
bear
exposed the soldier will sound the alarm
that was close
[Music]
at a safe distance she sucks up the
ant's juice
until nothing is left but an empty shell
and she disappears
back into the Shadows
as the spider leaves the field of battle
a new brigade of combatant centers
[Music]
for survival they must fight to the
death
The Tropical Paradise of the South
Pacific beautiful today
but it's not always been this way
[Music]
human Wars end
unlike the Eternal war that rages
beneath the tropical waters
The Reef is a Battleground
each of the Warriors uses specialized
weapons
ingenious tactics
power and speed
in pursuit of Victory and survival
oh
the broad Club cuttlefish
she's an unlikely looking predator
[Music]
soft frilly body inspires little fear
more glamorous than deadly as a strange
hypnotic light show plays across her
skin
it's the last show her prey will ever
see
today this weapon of mass destruction is
focusing on creation
foreign
she's laying eggs deep in the coral
where they're protected from predators
after laying the female is exhausted
she's not as quick as she once was
and the war of the reef
claims another
but not before the Cuttlefish completed
her life's mission
cuttlefish hatch as Tiny replicas of
adults
an army of Miniatures ready to take
their mother's place on the battlefield
[Music]
if just a couple survive
then the losses are balanced
foreign
force is complete
without Dominion of the air
movies are the ultimate in Aerial
bombardment Technology
dive bombing is now recognized as one of
the most accurate and destructive forms
of Air Attack
[Music]
the boobies Gather in a squadron of
hundreds
a Shoal of fish has come in Shore
but they are greeted by a blitzkrieg
piercing calls synchronize an assault
with a full belly this booby's sortie is
over she heads back to her nest and her
hungry chick but she's entering enemy
airspace and there are bogies incoming
if movies are the ultimate dive bombers
then frigate birds are the ultimate
fighter jets
the frigate lacks the diving ability of
the booby
so it wants to steal or catch
the booby tries to dodge the aerial
pirate
[Music]
her evasive moves are no match for the
frigid's speed and Power
[Music]
the only option is to regurgitate
mid-flight giving her lunge to the
island bullies
thank you
even then the fight isn't over
the frigates bicker amongst themselves
for scraps of booby vomit
[Music]
between the thread of the frigates and
the dangers of hunting and the pounding
surf line for a buoy is certainly a dog
fight
not all will make it home
ghost crabs usually sip the sands for
food
but they're always on the lookout for
something meteor
in this war the carnivores must risk
everything for victory
because without victory
there is no survival
it's time to fall in
for a formidable military unit
this Army is armed with deadly teeth
Claws and Agility
but that's not all that puts them in
contention for the title of the world's
deadliest
their intelligence and Teamwork Makes
them an elite fighting unit
a cape Cobra the most venomous snake in
Africa
but it's no match
for the meerkat Force
much more challenging is a multitude of
rival Fighters
the neighboring Clan wants to conquer
their abundant Homeland
meerkats will fight to the death when
the stakes are this high
come on
it's all about more
[Music]
the Patriots drive off their rivals
the battle may be won
but the war for survival always rages
and no one gets out alive
Africa's Serengeti Plains are one of the
bloodiest war zones on Earth
thank you
the greatest War here may not be between
predator and prey
but between two of the most ferocious
carnivores
lions
hyenas
they have overlapping territories
same taste and prey
[Music]
it is to battle
for money
hyenas are prolific Hunters
they separate one wildebeest from The
Herd
[Applause]
and Chase it until it's too tired to run
any longer
but the sound of the Chase has attracted
unwanted attention
the hyenas are being mugged
their calls attract more clan members
reinforcements arrive quickly
though much smaller
the hyenas are not to be taken lightly
their bite force is similar to that of
the Lion
evolved to crush bone
the lionesses retreat
but Victory is brief
over 500 pounds of teeth muscle and
attitude
turn the tide
foreign
s are a great threat to hyenas and are
responsible for over half of all hyena
deaths
while hyenas may not be able to take on
an adult male lion
young vulnerable cubs look like an
opportunity not to be missed
Lux can be deceiving
[Music]
laughs
foreign
battle is over
one of Nature's biggest battles is about
to begin
as massive brown bears
orcas
and whales brace themselves for their
finest hour
[Music]
to do big damage you need a big payload
this is what power looks like
brown bears are the biggest land
carnivore
weighing in at over 1700 pounds
foreign
Brooks Falls in Alaska is the front line
of the bear War
the usually solitary males
crammed together
forced to compete for the best fishing
spot
thank you while deaths are rare in
conflicts between adult males
Cubs are a different story
they are a kind of competition too
for the mother if a male can kill all of
a female's Cubs she may come back into
season and possibly meet with him
so a female approaching the falls with
their cops May pay a tragic price for
her supper
he's barely finished his first course
and now visitors
without a reservation
the miniature Marauders stand up to the
bully and
some
not only do they repel this threat but
backed up by Mom they also bully every
fair in sight out of their catches
they aren't Kings of the falls yet
but they have potential
the biggest carnivores can wreak havoc
on an enormous scale
humpback whales can consume up to 3 000
pounds of fish each day
[Music]
decimate an entire Shoals in a single
mouthful
to find the biggest Shoals whales must
make huge migrations from their breeding
grounds in the tropics
but another massive carnivore is waiting
for them
orcas hunt and pack earning them a title
Wolves of the sea
a gray whale in her calf is a exactly
the target they are looking for
orcas weigh in at over 15 000 pounds
but the wave can be up to five times
that size
it's the cap that they're after
[Music]
pack
the mother swims under her calf to
protect it
[Music]
but the calf slips back
the orcas take full advantage
repeatedly
they bite at its fins
until the calf can no longer resist
drowns
the Predator's first gorge on the
Delicacies
tongue and lips
[Music]
the huge calf easily satisfies the
enormous hunger of the salute crew
size teamwork strategy and Ingenuity all
combined in Nature's elite units to get
an almost unopposable fighting force
[Music]
thank you